Let's get back to the phones where people
are waiting.
We will go first to our caller from country
code 96.
It's country code 96.
Who is this?
I know.
Yes, yes, I can.
Well, I'm, I'm, I'm from Jordan.
Hey, how are you?
Good.
I'm doing that.
Um, my question, setting aside the new Trump
deal for visa Palestine, do we think, do you
think we should support the BDS movement?
If not, what do we have?
Oh.
Um, so we did a deep dive on the deal a couple
of days ago when, when it first came out and
the deal is basically a joke.
I mean you have impeached Donald Trump and
indicted Benjamin Netanyahu saying, Hey, we
made a deal and it's a, it's a complete farce.
It has no possibility of really accomplishing
anything.
Now that being said, I don't personally support
the BDS movement, but I do, um, want to see
a, a, a middle East peace process move forward.
I've outlined in detail exactly how I would
see that happening.
So I won't do it again since I spent about
15 minutes earlier this week doing it for
my audience.
But, uh, no the deal, the deal that was announced
by Trump and nothin, Yahoo was basically a
joke.
Well, uh, personally and my friends, we think
we should take it.
You think you should [inaudible] who do you
think Palestinians should take the deal?
Yeah.
Interesting.
Why is that?
Well, the first time I did want to just, I
bought them.
Sorry, what was that?
I missed that.
W we think like it's the board that finally,
yes it would establish a board, it would establish
it's a path to a Palestinian state with a
lot of caveats and question marks and requirements.
But there is a path to one yet.
No it's not.
We already lost the war so we get what you
get.
So you're, you're, you live in Jordan, but
are you Palestinian?
I gather,
yeah, I'm [inaudible].
I see.
And you, you would like this deal, you want
the deal to be taken?
Well, I don't like it, but I would like, like
a beast plate and I don't think we got a win
and I know that way.
Interesting.
So would you like to see, I read the, I read
a, that Palestinian leaders rejected the deal
outright because it includes some annexation
of West bank land.
How do you feel about that
when the will live, you live in Palestine,
it's already annexed with us.
What are you talking about?
In other words, you don't see any practical
difference in a sense.
I'm trying to, I'm trying to follow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There is no practical difference.
So yeah, if you go to Palestine, there is
a military check boy.
Yes there is the Australian army can, can,
can go and whatever when, whenever the like,
interesting.
So you, you, you would take the deal.
Do you, are, are the people, friends and family
of yours, are they on board or do they have
a different view?
Don't know.
Some friends have, I don't think that my family
would like [inaudible]
I do.
I see, I see.
Yeah.
That, that's not your problem.
I'm fairly liberal, so.
Right.
Okay.
Listen, uh, I think I understood your name
was, was a, is that, was that right?
That I have that right?
Um, yeah, it's, I'm just [inaudible].
Mmm, okay.
All right.
Very good.
Well listen, I so appreciate hearing from
you and I wish you best of luck.
We'll put you in our caller ID system and
I hope to hear from you again.
All right.
Thank you.
Take care.
Very interesting phone call.